صناعه السينما والدراما تغيرت بشكل جذري
خلال العشرين عام الماضيه السيناريو وحده
لا يكفي الان وتكنولوجيا المتطوره وعناصر
الابهار البصري من دقه عرض وجرافيكس اصبحت
ايضا جزءا اصيلا في هذه الصناعه الان مع
صعود منصات البث الرقميه تطور ايضا
الشاشات التلفزيون كذلك اجهزه الكمبيوتر
والهواتف المحموله اصبحت المنافسه مشتعله
حيث تمنح تلك الخدمات دقه صوره وتجربه
مشاهده قريبه لصلاه العرض التقليديه حتى
ان الحديث اليوم يدور حول اختفاء صالات
السينما كما نعرفها في المستقبل القريب
يعني ماكولا فشار ولا بوبكورن ولا شيء هلا
صار في نتفليكس
مشاهد هذه اصبحت ملائمه لنمط الحياه
السريع المشاهد يختار ما يريد
مشاهدته في اي وقت وبسرعه التي يرغب بها
فاصبح امر طبيعي ان يقضي صناع المسلسل
سنوات لتحضير موسم واحد وينتهي منه
المشاهدون ايش بجلسه واحده
معي شويه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ارض الاحلام الانغام وفي هذه الايام انها
ارض حرب الاحجام بين الشاشه والمنصه واذ
نتحدث عن 20 عاما من الافلام نقول اهلا
بكم في عالم صعود العمالقه الجدد المنصات
هل يقتل انتاج المنصات السينما كما
عرفناها وكما حددتها هوليود هذا هو السؤال
المقلق
[موسيقى]
اتيت امين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
العربيه تحتفل بعيدها العشرين وبينما
نتحدث عن 20 سنه افلام نتذكر انه في منتصف
تلك العشرين بدا صعود المنصات مع ولاده
نتفليكس وقبلها بخمس سنوات ولدت منصه
يوتيوب وكلتهما نقلتا استهلاك المحتوى الى
مكان اخر تماما فاين نتجه في العشرين سنه
المقبله